right so this is how functional
components work and this is why you are
also able to use const within the
function components because it does not
mutate the variable it actually creates
a whole new function
hey everyone welcome back and in this
video we'll be taking a look at one of
the most important things i believe you
should know as a react developer that
how functional components actually work
in react now i'm not talking about how
to write components but internally in
react what is happening
when you use a functional component and
we'll take a look at how they differ
from a class-based component as well so
this is going to be a very very very
informative video for all those react
developers out there so make sure you
watch it till the end also if you're new
here make sure you leave a like and
subscribe to the channel to keep on
receiving such quality updates on a
daily basis on gold dam this video is a
part of code dam's t-shirt giveaway
program for the month if you want to
take part and win an amazing go damn
t-shirt all you have to do is leave a
comment on this video about what you
think and that's it you are eligible if
your comment gets a heart from code damn
you will win a t-shirt for absolutely
free all right let's start with react
functional component so react functional
components was not the cool way to do
components as long as there was not
hooks the concept of hooks introduced in
there because there was no state right
but when the concept of hooks was
introduced then you can create
actually functional truly stateful
components in react by just using
function before that we had to use class
let's say this is your component like
this in react where we have a simple
button a state and on clicking this
button we just have
the counter incrementing right now what
i want you to understand is what
exactly happens when you click on this
button so
what react does internally is
obviously if you have all also displayed
this counter somewhere you will see
whenever you click on this button the
counter will increase from one two three
four and so on so you can see you can
clearly see x is changing right but this
sounds a bit weird if you're seeing this
for the first time and you see that
you're using a const modifier here for
declaring this x variable right that
means you technically cannot do x equal
to 2 but you know x equal to 3 or x
equal to 4 you cannot do this stuff this
is not allowed because you are using a
const that means this x cannot change
value and sure enough we don't even do
that ourselves but does react internally
can it do that of course not because
react is part of javascript this is
javascript this is react so obviously it
cannot break the rules of javascript
itself so what react actually do in this
case when you're using a functional
component is that it calls this function
again
but with a new x value now let's see how
that happens so the way i like to
imagine this is in a form of a react
universe right so react has a small
universe of its own where all these
functional
updates reside now let's say this is the
first function
which function render which has happened
right on the screen so this is the very
first render that means you're seeing a
zero on the screen
and x is also 0 in this react functional
call right so the moment you click on
this button
you know you click on this this function
gets executed and what this is doing is
that within that react universe it's
going to create another function another
new function it's going to call this
function again but what's going to
happen is that this time
when this function is getting called
this x comma set x you know that this
set x is going to receive a function
anyway from you state but this function
gets called
in a similar way right this is the exact
same line which happens as well the only
difference is in this universe in this
function of the universe this expression
right here returns 0
but in this universe or this iteration
this expression right here returns you a
1 instead of a 0 which makes all the
difference right 1 comma the function
basically because then the x becomes 1
and then set x becomes something else
right so now in this part of the
universe the x value is one and then of
course you have the set x as a function
modifier as well so what's essentially
happening is every single time you call
this set modifier react renders that
function again as a different part in
the same universe and then replaces the
use state value with a new one now why
this is important this is important
because you can very easily
perform some weird behavior especially
when you use use effect or stuff like
that so we will discuss about use effect
later but what we can discuss right now
is that this u state right here you can
see can now work even with following the
javascript rules why because you can see
i'm not mutating the value inside a
function i'm actually rendering a whole
new function right and whatever this is
returned whatever this function returns
in the second iteration that actually
gets created as a react you know new dom
right so if this func this was the
function which called it it's gonna be
replaced and this new this new function
right here which had x equal to one
value would be created and then this
would be compared with the original dom
on the screen and react will say that
hey we have update to this particular
node therefore dom please go ahead and
update this and this will appear on the
screen for the user right so this is how
function components work and this is why
you are also able to use const within
the function components because it does
not mutate the variable it actually
creates a whole new function there are
very interesting use cases which happen
when you use for example like i said
when you when you start using use effect
and use effect plus set interval or set
timeout when you use this stuff you
actually understand how this behavior
really works how this transition really
happens in from one function to another
and so on but yeah this is something for
another day maybe a bit of more
practical instead of this
theoretical understanding but yeah i
mean i i hope that you got the idea how
react functional components actually
work on every single state of date they
create a new function they never reuse
the previous one wait in an ideal world
this previous function should be
destroyed and you know garbage collected
and all that stuff but a lot of times
like i said this is one of the clearest
example where you can you know just have
this zombie function sitting right here
eating some variables some memory
resources even running some side effects
possibly so you don't want to do that
but yeah like i said that will involve a
lot of use effect and you know some
tricks and tips so maybe that's
something for another video that is all
for this video hopefully you understood
how to work with react and how react
components really work react function
components i'm gonna see you in the next
video really soon if you liked it make
sure you leave a like and subscribe to
the channel thank you so much for
watching and i'm gonna see you in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
you